countdown in five oh three two one what
up nephew else my welcome to another
episode of genius brain podcasts I am
your host David show and introduce
yourself
I am holster Joe Jitsu kala what's up
y'all
we just got back from a delicious meal
of Korean barbecue oh yeah yo man a lot
of people don't know what Korean
barbecue is son Korean barbecue is the
[ __ ] it's not that traditional American
barbecue that you're used to we're
talking about sliced thin pieces of
brisket yep we're talking about some
beef tongue sometimes we're talking
about sometimes beef belly rib eye steak
rib eye steak short rib it's the [ __ ]
man if it bacon pieces fat a lot y'all
whatever pork jowl intestines yeah Oh
some people don't like intestines issues
I started liking it now it's good right
like it like if you get the if you get
the don't get small intestine not large
yeah the long one tastes like Dookie
yeah it's like [ __ ] rubber Dookie tip
if you get the large intestines how do I
be waiting that [ __ ] I should taste like
rubber band with Dookie yeah exactly
it's this it's the the small intestine
is the lower part right that's where all
the [ __ ] is and I yeah I guess so yeah
and the large intestine like I guess
like Dookie as it has to do it yet so
it's just like food maybe like beef fat
that's like crispy uh-huh and that's
what it tastes like
mm-hmm on man it's delicious
yeah man so we're just gonna get right
into it one of the topics that a lot of
people have been asking about it
and I think that I've been wanting to
talk about it's like I had whole cancel
culture yeah that's been really big
right now yeah it's where people are
finding out anything and everything
about somebody they want to take it oh
you [ __ ] yeah and they're literally if
canceled culture is literally what it
sounds like it's you trying to take
somebody down and there's like a certain
type of either like accomplishment from
it and joy from it now mind you from
what we've seen especially with like the
me to movement you know there's a lot of
positive stuff that comes out of it
summertime like [ __ ] what's his name
Harvey Weinstein yeah
[ __ ] creep I mean the great thing
that came out of that
is we all known like [ __ ] like this goes
down in Hollywood or in the corporate
world or whatever like you know people
use their position of power to rape
women or whatever and it's like out now
and it's like oh [ __ ] some interesting
comments that I remember that I read was
when we were talking about the whole
Bill Cosby thing and we actually know
somebody who were you guys mentioned
this story to me would there was that
story about the hair stylist yeah yeah
yeah makeup artist yeah that was talking
about how back in the day she got
harassed by Bill Cosby yeah he
straight-up came up and grabbed yeah he
called her boob yeah and then he was
like there's nothing you can [ __ ] do
about it yeah yeah and I think I don't
think a lot of people understand because
there was a couple of comments where
they mentioned well if you guys knew
this stuff you guys should have said
something it's like me it's like well
first of all that was a hearsay story
that we heard through somebody else
that's not fact it's not fact this is
something that I heard yeah so this is
something that we heard from somebody
else so it's already a watered down
account that it came through to other
people uh-huh so we don't we're not out
here to ruin somebody's career on
something based on hearsay yeah right
and this is this is generally what
happens - yeah and obviously for me to
like Bill Cosby I didn't want to believe
that [ __ ] yeah yo I adamantly defended
that dude I mean I even had hearsay
about um Harvey Weinstein yeah one of my
buddies he's a producer in Vietnam and
Harvey Weinstein his company was they
would license movies Asian movies and in
like and then like release it here in
the States right now so he was he had a
trip out in whether it was Hong Kong or
whatever but one of his actors had an
opportunity to work with him because he
was seeking her out specifically so
after the meeting with with him
they were like oh you want to talk about
like a role and then and she's like sure
so they went up to his office or hotel
room or whatever it was and then she
came down and she's like [ __ ] that guy
I'm never gonna work with them and then
she never got the role she never got an
opportunity but basically she told
everybody like yeah that guy just tried
to [ __ ] creep on me and he solicit he
just said like you want the role like
[ __ ] yeah then I already knew like this
is like 2008
Ellis but when I heard this story 2008
or 2009
so it was like long [ __ ] time ago man
and and but it's funny that everybody in
the industry knew these things or who
has met him and how how open he was so
the problem is I think everyone [ __ ]
knew a lot of people knew because he was
like invincible there was there's a lot
of fear and now I have a friend - who
not too long ago experienced not to that
extent but she kind of experienced how
somebody can use their power over them
in entertainment because it's highly
career based yeah so for example so she
she does like makeup and like a wardrobe
and all the other stuff right so how is
kind of how it was kind of explained to
me is this it goes okay so your job so
for me it's my job to dress up this
actor or whatever right and this actor
on set has all this power so mind you if
this actor is not happy he feels upset
this whole film is based on this person
yeah and it doesn't go through then well
everybody's [ __ ] yeah so it's it's
it's beyond just her her job that's
everyone
yeah careers on the line and if if this
actor is like throwing off mmm his
moment like let's say like he has a bad
experience with I don't know like the
makeup artist yeah and then he gets
upset and he doesn't want to do his role
or he can't perform well because now
he's just so upset at how rude that
makeup artist was then it's like you
just [ __ ] up the whole day for
everybody yeah so for like in her case
it was it was kind of to the point where
he clearly was making a lot of like
sexual advances at her and you know she
was brushing him off whatever she was
handling it very well because she's has
experience she has experienced this
before yeah but how she was explained to
me was this she goes well let me put it
to you like this because I asked her
like what [ __ ] just tell him to [ __ ]
off she goes well David it's not that
easy cuz you have to think about it like
this I come in I say hey don't do this
blah blah blah blah I feel really
uncomfortable with you he gets pissed
off when it comes time for me to dress
him up which I guess like this has
happened to her before on a smaller
scale he goes I don't like I like this
[ __ ] you're not doing your job right
[ __ ] this like I'm not acting thing I'm
not doing this you
it gets pawn her she loses her job yeah
then she's gonna have even a harder time
booking another job because she's known
as a person that sucks on job and just
actors off so this is the type of power
that they have over people and I didn't
really think about that and these people
in position they [ __ ] know it
yeah they [ __ ] know it too and I I
never had that perspective before
because in my mind I was just saying you
know why don't you just stand up for
yourself and tell the dude to [ __ ] off
like it's not that easy because these
people are the are the gatekeepers to
another job or another job opportunity
that's why it's nice that things are
catching up to them yeah because it's
like all the people that you [ __ ] did
wrong all the people that like couldn't
stand up to you yeah now it's catching
up [ __ ] it's okay and it's nice
it's nice to watch yeah cuz it's it's
almost like payback's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it really is though
men and I feel like a lot of people did
get away with a lot because they knew
nobody was going to say [ __ ] or it just
seems so far-fetched to a lot of yeah
and even for me it seemed far-fetched
like it was just a story but it didn't
like sit in my stomach is something real
right so somebody would tell me these
stories I'm like yeah I could see that
happening but like for us like it's
already watered down by the time it
comes to us yeah so we whistle blow who
the [ __ ] is gonna listen right I mean
like [ __ ] like the whole art Kelly [ __ ]
came out yeah I mean a lot of things
been happening and we know some people
that that's like old-school Hollywood
like they've been in since like the the
80s and 90s yeah I like and what I hear
is that today a lot of people are are
scared in many ways scared because like
the internet [ __ ] going digital and
things like that is is putting mad
pressure like there's there's no feature
film industry anymore yeah it's like
unless they're making a [ __ ] big
blockbuster thing or a Marvel movie like
yeah there's no middle budget it's
either independent companies doing
digital content or Netflix produce
things there's really no film industry
mm-hmm everything's moving the TV or
digital or whatever and so their careers
are all in the line not only that like a
lot of these actors these powerhouse
actors they're aging yeah although
there's an end there's no next
generation really that
stand up up to par to these guys yeah
and there's a lot of shifts happening
and on top of that now with the me to
movement now with all this like people
going against the fraudulent Hollywood
world there are so many things that are
like the old guard is gonna change yeah
it's gonna it's an interesting time man
and so there's so much pressure they
don't have as much as they used to have
like now it's tainted like the secret's
out a lot of shit's gonna start
surfacing yeah a new media kind of
opened up this gateway because of you
don't have to tell just one person and
that person who doesn't believe you it
doesn't have to be like that right so
let's say you told somebody who was very
significant about this problem and they
just don't believe you well that's kind
of just how it ends right right back in
a day yeah it's like well I needed to
tell this executive that this happened
but they don't believe me that that's
the end of the story now you could get
everybody on your side yeah and that's
what's cool about it build your case and
like the whole Cosby thing if it was
just one woman that told somebody within
that circle that this is what they're
like no that's not Bill yeah [ __ ] are
you talking about ten pop out there like
I've been Kwai looted yeah you know like
like thirty or fifty like like it's
crazy
it's kind of hard to deny at this point
what sucks about it though is the people
who take advantage of movements yeah and
then it kind of discredits it because
during the me to movement there were
there were there were women that were
using it and falsely accusing guys that
never raped them or whatever yeah since
people were just so heightened does that
Bob mentality they're like [ __ ] it I
don't care if he's you know o innocent
or not let's get him [ __ ] Birnam and
that's when it went too far
yes it was like ah man no like now now I
like I'm all for justice but like we
can't treat everyone like Frankenstein
you know like it's yeah that's that's
[ __ ] up yeah it got really weird too
especially with some of some you know
somebody put this out I forgot it was on
Twitter but I agree with this a hundred
percent and I kind of wanted to do a
video on this but because she explained
it so well there was really no point
yeah but she
kind of warned women of a lot of other
women who are in guise of somebody who
is there is support for females but
they're really not know right and so
this kind of goes hand in hand and she
used Kim Kardashian as an example all
right so she is this woman that says
girls it's all about you be badass it's
all you know all this other stuff but
our actions speak otherwise in terms of
this like you suck the dude's dick to
get where you're at yeah exactly right
yeah so are you a part of this me too
movement and you're really not but you
know for somebody like that they're
trying to capitalize on this movement to
make them look good yeah so they are not
I guess quote-unquote I hate this word
but an ally they are somebody who's
using that movement in benefit of them
right up so you sucked your dick all the
way to the top right you're telling
women you should love the way that you
are but you have asked implants tit
implants whatever that you have you have
Botox got your lips pumped yeah like
what the [ __ ] are you saying
like it's not all natural like how are
you how are you telling these women to
be comfortable with who you are and love
yourself when you're the person who has
the financial means to change any part
of your body whatever you want because
you actually don't love the way that you
look yeah and people don't have access
to that so that crazy she would say [ __ ]
like that and expect not to expect to
get burned yeah like who the [ __ ] are
you you know that blows my mind yeah so
you know obviously when Kim Kardashian
she was like trying to hop onto that
meat to boom it she's got a feeling for
it she guys she should yeah as well as
other people who's taken opportunities
because what happens is like let's say
there was an actress and she's like [ __ ]
it I'll suck a dick yeah cuz I mean I've
said it before yeah if I could get on a
movie I sucked the [ __ ] out of Jackie
Chan's dick put me I'll rush our
[ __ ] ten dude oh [ __ ] he's in a
wheelchair
spitting him around in the chair but I
mean all jokes aside right like there is
a woman that was cool with it
that was like [ __ ] it I'll do it it's
gonna get me to the top but then what
that what ends up happening is like now
dudes like Weinstein are like oh [ __ ] it
was that easy well I could do it again
maybe they all down maybe a lot of women
were cool to do this [ __ ] yeah like I
feel like those women that try to hop on
that me to boom it like it's you're not
a part of that movement because you used
whatever your body your sexuality to get
what you want out of that situation it
was a
harder thing right you traded something
for something got what you wanted and
now you're on the top yeah but how can
you say that to other other women and
support them when you basically
prostituted yourself yeah and for them
it wasn't like that they are told the
other way around Eagles you do this or
you won't have this job yeah exactly
that's a completely different situation
that's like a drug dealer that's like
joining all the people like yeah fair
and square work hard it's like well yeah
you did work hard for drug dealing but
at the same time man like you're not
paying taxes and you're not doing what
the rest of the people are doing yeah so
you can't March with us it's not the
same it's not the same [ __ ] thing
yeah I think the problem that I think
when people want to talk about canceled
culture the problem with it is now it's
like it's become a sport and a hobby to
to shut people down it's that it's that
it's that crab mentality right like
let's pull down the guy on the top yeah
I could use them to climb on top like we
got to cancel this person you gotta kill
the [ __ ] are you and the problem that I
have with that is like people are
walking around like you're [ __ ] does not
[ __ ] stink like you're [ __ ] your
shits the same as my [ __ ] it's poop baby
we all poop it at all [ __ ] stinks I
love how people want to be so like take
like oh I'm gonna take the moral higher
ground but then like they're such
[ __ ] hypocrites yeah like I'm getting
so sick of that like I understand we are
all hypocrites to a certain extent but
people are trying to burn some other
human being yet as if they haven't done
worse like remember the guy with the
hole the Chinese dress thing yes that
[ __ ] Asian fast that [ __ ] was like
might my my cultures not a costume right
but then you they found all all to all
these old tweets and he's using the
n-word like helping people but like
these black people this and that it's
derogatory way - yeah it's like who the
[ __ ] do you think you are man I know and
that's hilarious man it's hilarious that
biblical saying man let the first person
without sin cast the first stone
[ __ ] or in David's David's Dave
Chappelle's he he who is without sin
cast the first stone
and I shall smoke it
representing men and it's it's if you
are going to roast somebody for doing
something terrible in their past that
they've learned from that you should be
able to reflect that upon yourself -
it's slightly okay take a look at your
past right did you learn from it did you
grow and if you're so comfortable going
ahead and judging somebody else then you
you damn well should be comfortable for
somebody I was checking out your tweets
or whatever you've done in the past and
judge you for it as well that [ __ ] just
recently happened to Andrew Zimmern oh
that's right yeah like he basically said
that Asian restaurants in the Midwest
taste like horse [ __ ] or whatever along
the lines of that but he said their
horse [ __ ] right yeah which I don't
disagree with being an Asian person
who's ate a lot of Midwest restaurants
compared to Asia compared to LA compared
to areas that are predominantly Asian if
that is the standard I would consider it
horse [ __ ] yeah wait was this what did
he say this at it was on his um it was
on his new show it's not it's not
Bizarre Foods it's another one yeah so
he said it on the show and that people
were upset about that yeah you know you
know what I I
I mean like even though I agree that
that it does taste like [ __ ] a lot of
the times yeah like I also read why
people were mad and it also made sense
and I kind of felt bad afterwards mmm
cuz like the argument that a lot of
these Asian restaurants were making like
it's like man my parents they came to
this country they didn't have [ __ ] we
moved in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and we had to figure out how to fork out
living for ourselves and we created a
restaurant and you kiss you just can't
serve authentic Chinese food in the
middle of Kansas or whatever it is yeah
because you know that the palate is just
different they want PF Changs
they want you know like like I don't
know like white folks they're scared of
ethnic food most most most cases right
like yeah unless they're around a lot of
unless they're around a lot of like
Asians or whatever then they're like
though ease into it but in most cases
they want that like
random Chinese food that's off the
[ __ ] when you're on a long road trip
there's like a Chinese restaurant in the
middle of nowhere and you get that
[ __ ] hot and sour sauce with the
wonton crisps yeah that Iser and you get
your beef and broccoli and orange
chicken and things like that
that shit's cool that is good you know I
ain't gonna lie I [ __ ] love that yeah
I love that Americanized Chinese food
but I think if we're gonna compare
apples to apples right yeah like it's
hard to say all of them suck because
there are some good restaurants oh yeah
for sure but generally speaking if we're
saying generally like the majority I
would say at least 75% which is majority
right at least 75% of restaurants that
I've personally tried out in the Midwest
doesn't make a decent beef and broccoli
if you're gonna compare that to like
beef and broccoli in LA or San Francisco
yeah or whatever right yeah and even
that's not authentic but that's fine but
if if and we're talking about someone
and Andrew Z he's probably a eating way
more authentic [ __ ] than I've ever had
that's full eight 17 different types of
Asian cow dick he exactly the Chinese
dick restaurant right it's so much dick
it's unreal dude yeah like goose dick a
big [ __ ] elephant dick Tiger dick yes
like now that is a real Chinese man you
oughta mean like so when this person
who's an authority on food which I
highly respect and he's a he's even way
more Asian authentic Asian foods than
most Asian Americans yep when he comes
out and he says yeah it tastes like
horse [ __ ] I do agree like it just
[ __ ] sucks that everyone else is like
you [ __ ] racist you shouldn't you
don't you shouldn't you have no place to
say things like this everyone's mad yeah
it's mad because they're mad because a
white guy shouldn't have an opinion on
Asian food which I highly disagree with
because I think that is so racist to say
that other cultures cannot comment on
other cultures yeah I you know my thing
is it's kind of weird because he floats
in a very weird place because he has
been and eaten more bentham more Asian
that I have right he has eaten more
Asian food than I have yeah and he has
cooked more Asian food than I have yep
so Who am I to tell a chef that's also
like a connoisseur of food mm-hmm what
the what authenticity is exactly dude
like I don't have like just because I'm
Asian I can't really have that
conversation when it comes to food that
I grew up with right but I I don't know
why people don't look at him as maybe he
has an authority of it just because of
maybe his skin color that's really about
it and that to me is just like prejudice
yeah because this happened to this
happened in like a like a Ubisoft or
Sony commercial - okay there was a there
was a white guy who like dedicated his
life to taiko drumming uh-huh and um you
know I think he's a professor he lived
in Japan and like he's he's like he's a
hardcore enthusiast of this like
Japanese drumming thing so when they
came out with his video game they had
him like do they do the drums and do the
promo for it right and a lot of people
were getting mad at Sony and they're
just like why are you [ __ ] letting
this whitewash what don't why you
whitewashing Japanese content and all
this stuff and then like again it was a
Twitter warrior she she closed her
account but she was just like this is
what I'm talking about like like what's
what's the word that they call cultural
appropriation yeah cultural promotion
god [ __ ] health but that term but but
here's a thing like that was to me
cultural appreciation and this person
that was saying is she was like Filipino
she's not even Japanese so she's
fighting and speaking on behalf of
Japanese people and I was like yo I'm
Japanese and I see this as cultural
appreciation
it's though someone who dedicates like
20 plus years learning the drumming like
trying to give it like respect and also
keeping it alive like hell yeah dude
that's [ __ ] awesome that's a lot of
appreciation I don't give a damn if he's
white
that's a weird [ __ ] - it's like yeah
some Filipino girl is mad about a
Japanese taiko drum like I don't
understand that [ __ ] yo yeah you know
people don't even realize to like Jim
where she was mad as she was like what
Sony you couldn't find a Japanese man to
do the job and I'm like what who the
[ __ ] cares yeah like it's dope and he's
doing there and if it's a part of his
life then why not and also too you know
people don't realize meant like Japan
specifically is one of the biggest
countries when it comes to exporting
culture yeah that's like one of their
biggest [ __ ] thing yeah like
economically speaking like they export
culture like a [ __ ] same thing
with your light like Hawaii does that a
lot too and so you know it kind of goes
hand in hand with like there was a
conversation I had with uh
with Z about this where P Diddy
he put out this thing where there was a
bunch of white kids they were dancing on
top of cars you know enjoying like music
or something you know like black you
know what he calls black hip-hop yeah
right so to that credit of saying like
this is our culture this is black
culture yeah and a lot of people felt a
little weird about it
it was like 50 where 50 percent was
agreeing with Diddy and the other 50
kind of wasn't because he goes this is
our culture and we're letting these like
white kids kind of go run rampant with
it this is ours we need to reacquire
this stuff yeah but how I saw the other
side what they said was like okay true
however think about it like this
your people that you're selling this to
are these white kids they're buying it
you're exporting this and you're making
a profit off of it right so now that
you've sold it to the kids you got them
to love the stuff that you're putting
yeah I want to be a part of it now they
want to be a part of now you're like
okay you could buy it but don't but
don't enjoy it yeah so it's like how
does that really work out and that kind
of goes with a lot of Asian culture too
we export it out so a lot of people are
going to appreciate it yeah I mean I
guess a good example of how [ __ ] up it
is about the cultural appropriation
thing is like when we were in Japan like
my mom wanted always wanted a daughter
so she wanted to put Jess in a kimono
because when women turn like 18 or
whatever they take photos ooh in a
kimono yeah it's like a it's almost like
a Japanese kimchi Aneta yeah right so so
Jess didn't want to do it cuz she
thought she was gonna be disrespectful a
bunch of tourists do that [ __ ] though
exactly but I was like no no you don't
get it like in Japan they love it exact
they want they want black people they
want like middle-eastern they want
everybody to wear the clothes they want
them to like be happy and and and and
experience the culture that way and but
she felt like she was gonna disrespect
it like you know like how how white
people put on like those those Halloween
costumes of other cultures and [ __ ] or
something along the lines of that and I
was like no you shouldn't be embarrassed
like they love this [ __ ] and that's how
bad it's gotten to where like she can't
even enjoy appreciating culture because
she's constantly worried especially
because she's white
yeah and it's it's it's a sensitive
subject I feel like in America just
because of our social background here's
yeah when it comes to you know we talk
about just white and black relations
yeah and but if when you're in the
country and the people in the country
are telling you that they would like for
you to wear it yeah that's different
that's different that you're not in the
States
yeah you know and and I've seen that too
I've seen everybody do that when they go
to Japan yeah and there's a reason why
they have shops and stores specifically
for foreigners to try it on yeah and do
it yeah like it's not like there you'll
see somebody Japan look at you like what
are you doing there like look at that
yeah yeah you know they're they're
literally like oh he looks handsome oh
she looks cute
that guy looks a little funny like
that's all they're doing yeah it's like
they kind of did to them it's actually
entertaining watching foreigners put on
their clothes yeah everyday they have to
put on foreigner clothes yeah jeans
t-shirt all that stuff you know what I
mean like and I feel like when hopefully
what people do when they do go to like
let's say a country like Japan yeah
they're not bringing their American
lifestyle and telling people in Japan to
conform to them they're doing the
opposite and being respectful and
conforming to what is appropriate over
there yeah but I like I like how you
brought up the whole history thing yeah
because there's a fine line between
cultural appreciation and appropriation
yeah because we already have a history
of people profiting from you know like
minority culture yeah like bastardized
version of it and a good example are the
McDo Joe's like yeah like you have a
handful of white guys that
kind of fetishize karate they don't know
anything about it but they watch a few
movies and then like maybe they take a
Taekwondo class and then they get like
like a yellow belt and then they just
you know go out and start their own dojo
yeah and they pretend like a lot of fake
Asian [ __ ] yeah you know what I mean
it's it just it's so inauthentic and
it's like oh you guys are just [ __ ]
playing a game yeah and you know to
Diddy's credit to like I understand
where he's coming from right because
it's how I see it as this is okay cool
so we made this product right and we
kind of did it in a way to empower our
culture and this is something that I
used to give me fun of about or people
would think of me as a low class person
but now that it's on I guess I can his
mind now that some white kids are doing
and now it's cool yeah like what the
[ __ ] but I guess you know going back to
the other side it's that was something
that you did a great job and you did
make it cool so now these kids they want
to be a part of it so you changed that
perception I mean worldwide everyone why
people are listening to hip-hop the
rapping and look at hip-hop and [ __ ]
Asian man yeah my trap music ah yeah I
know she's [ __ ] crazy cuz yeah it's
it's yo when I heard I forgot there's
this group out in Asia but they do like
hood trap music but it's like in [ __ ]
Cantonese that [ __ ] makes me laugh so
hard I'm sorry like it's like the 88
Rising boys yeah yeah yeah all those
guys I'm not laughing at them because
it's ridiculous it's just I just never
thought you could put like Cantonese to
it I know it just sounds hard yeah
because Cantonese already sound like
you're trying to kill somebody you put
some hip-hop to that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
sounds real as [ __ ] yeah
yeah but when I get that it's it's
global now and I remember when I when I
started doing YouTube I used to get mad
at I think it's because the way that we
kind of speak whether it's like you're
from the Bay Area East LA or whatever
like there's a certain type of way that
you speak and that was kind of like a
past that you got only if you grew up in
that area but then I started hearing
everybody use these slang terms that
wasn't akin to who they are as a person
you know and so you would but that's but
yeah you're right like there's people
that don't even come from California and
then they're just like yo that's hella
tight' y'all
are you trying so hard dude yeah that's
what it felt like you know and yeah no
kids you don't mind you they grew up in
a very affluent white neighborhood are
we we know some fake-ass youtuber is
that that try extra [ __ ] hard to be
urban and [ __ ] and in when they speak
they sound like it's we regularly they
know how to switch from back they know
how to switch back and forth man yeah
like it's hard to deal with them the
most specifically them it's because for
them it's like a persona right I mean
they like to use it to their advantage
whenever they want but we just want them
to be them be themselves yeah but some
of these other kids they grew up
watching YouTube so much you can tell
the difference
exactly it's like for them like what's
your [ __ ] excuse man you didn't grow
up in their area you're not a [ __ ] 13
or old kid
I grew up watching this [ __ ] so like
these dudes so funny like we're not
gonna say names but I kid you not every
time they come up to me and have a
conversation with me number one like
I've mentioned this before I don't even
have like a hood ass accent like it's
like a slight mix because it's it's
something that I kind of grew up with
what I did grow up grow up with but you
know education was a big part of my life
so I had to learn how to flip in and out
of it a lot but every time the [ __ ]
come up to me they're just like you
almost up homie what's good like bro
relax man
you talk like better [ __ ] what's up
the [ __ ] is this are you in a [ __ ]
rap music video like no one [ __ ] does
that in real life yeah Dee do that
[ __ ] lik lipping [ __ ] with their
[ __ ] I call yeah yeah what's with the
[ __ ] they put the [ __ ] the lotion
on their hands type of [ __ ] yeah
what are you doing stop doing prayer
hands oh what's up man so I'm like black
people don't even do that on a regular
what the [ __ ] like chill the [ __ ] out
you know that's that's Ted that's that
[ __ ] that i [ __ ] hate and it kind of
makes me wonder it's like is that how
you perceived me as a human being like I
don't number one I don't even speak like
that dude like I don't even talk like
that so what the [ __ ] is it out of all
the people that you're gonna you know
put this front up for why me like
[ __ ] relax you know it always makes
me laugh too you know how like okay when
when your would not you but when people
around black people yeah
like they start to slowly urbanize a
little bit like right like it's it's
like what the [ __ ] for real yeah like
it's it's weird cuz go there's somebody
else too and you know her too like
[ __ ] crack up because this chick grew
up in the valley yeah and when I first
met her you know I'm talking to you know
this is clip I saw on YouTube of prior
to her trying to be a little more urban
as you can say like she's trying to
torque mesh it was bad [ __ ] did all
shoulders that [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] yeah it was that and I started
looking dying laughing cuz I saw that
clip of her but you know now what like I
noticed and I mentioned this to her
husband I was like yo do you notice that
every time this girl is in front of one
black person she's goes okay girl what's
good I seat you like it wouldn't the
[ __ ] is my god and I'm sitting there
just dying like my skin is crawling man
it's like oh why do people do that [ __ ]
I don't understand like yo chill the
[ __ ] out they're gonna like you either
way you're a dope person like you just
not even know it just it just does it
just happens you know it just happens -
and the funny thing is like they do that
around like the black folk they don't
even talk like that
that's hilarious it's like yo they don't
even talk like a Harvard graduate with
no accent yeah no no Ebonics or whatever
just straight-up like they sound like
Carlton banks and [ __ ] yeah you do
realize they grew up in the same area as
you so you guys already talked the same
huh but because she sees the color of
their skin she [ __ ] hands it up like
crazy now now mind you I'll say this
right so if I'm back in Sacramento I
guess like that that kind of like hood
lingo tends to come out a little more
because that's what I grew up with but
that's also true like Hawaiian locals oh
yeah yeah right my cousin like one time
you know I never heard him speak pidgin
cuz he's always been here in California
for the longest time but when they moved
back to Hawaii and then I started
talking to my was like man you sound
different yeah oh yeah it's cuz I'm when
I'm back here like my pigeon comes out
yeah like I never heard you yeah like
this my whole entire life like what the
[ __ ] did you get this yeah and I'm like
oh trip out bro
like it makes sense like cuz you're
going back to your hometown right yeah I
go back to my hometown or like even
Khalif understands - all right so
Khalifa now when we speak to each other
I talk to my best friend we speak a
certain way yeah it's still mainly like
this but then you know I'll ham it up a
little bit too because to be honest with
you that's how I used to speak the most
yeah
so how I've learned to kind of enunciate
my words and clean up the way that I
speak was mainly because I wanted to go
into entertainment and I was doing
stand-up yeah so I used to speak I mean
I still speak fast now but I used to
speak really [ __ ] fast and so I had
to learn how to slow that down and on
top of that the way that I spoke wasn't
really great in getting jobs like I
couldn't get a job yeah
so I learned how to clean up the way
that I spoke and then kind of you know I
guess as you say widen up a little bit
and you know it's it's a little natural
for me now I should pull out one of my
[ __ ] old videos so you used to talk
like a [ __ ] cholo dude that's awful
yeah it was thoughtful your you were
straight a Mexican bro too much
information and [ __ ] [ __ ] Bigfoot
days you know if you guys have any spare
time dude look up 9-1-1 call Victor
Fuentes yo Tim Timothy DeLaGhetto show
me this clarity of this cholo out in
content that did a 9 1 1 calls the
funniest [ __ ] you'll ever hear in your
life I mean I mean going back to this
whole cultural probe like all that stuff
is like where do you draw the line
because you have people that grew up
yeah like you know the only Asian kid in
a white neighborhood or a black
neighborhood or whatever right yeah or
even even like I remember my high school
was predominantly black and Hispanic and
we had like 5 white kids yeah and and
it's like the Eminem's of the group
right like whatever like how like they
don't know anything else you know like
all of their friends the people the
English that they're around listening to
like they kind of absorb that culture
yeah right so like who's to stay like
you got to act like your culture it's
it's that is their culture you mean you
know like if you grew up around like
like let's say all your friends are
black yeah and like you know even though
your parents
but they had they speak broken English
yeah and it's like that's where you
learn English that's where your
community is I mean that you're not
black but then where else are you gonna
learn English yeah like the sorbets
the best way to explain it is this it's
like yo have you seen a [ __ ] asian
person like in the UK yeah they sound
like they have a British jacket they
have so well what what like how you can
understand that but you can't understand
the other way around where somebody grew
up in a neighborhood where everybody
spoke with like a hood accent or saying
they're not gonna pick that [ __ ] up like
how do you not understand it so you
could understand it in an international
scale but it's different when it comes
to the United States and in like what
about like if corn rolls are in right
you grew up in a black neighborhood
cornrows are in and it's like everyone's
gaining them it's like I want to fit
into so you get them but then they go no
you can't cuz you're not black yeah I
put it to you like man I would have had
cornrows to my hair's too thin dude I
shoulda would have ripped I wanted to
but then I saw how painful it was and I
was like that [ __ ] is [ __ ] painful
dude like especially because after you
get your cornrows out like a lot of
people typically like Asian dudes they
get it they'll notice that a lot of
their hair falls out to [ __ ] cuz it's
tight it's tight as [ __ ] is itchy
yeah I mean there was none of this these
words existed back in high school like
people just did [ __ ] it's hard man just
because there's a lot of pain behind
this stuff so when they see somebody do
something when during the time that they
did it they got made fun of for it yeah
they think that it's unfair it's like
well what the [ __ ] how come when I did
it back in the day you guys were saying
all this racial [ __ ] to me but
suddenly when quote-unquote white person
does it now it's cool it's okay now now
you guys want to take credit for it so
there's there's that pain in that
history that people just can't get oh so
like it's like when black people did
like the afro hair then it was like it
was like being a rebel and it was like
whatever but then like or or that that
dreadlocks or whatever yeah and then now
if white people do the [ __ ]
dreadlocks or whatever then it's like so
cool and edgy exactly I was like sense
you made fun of my hair like my
dreadlocks and [ __ ] just culturing mine
you said it was smelly you you know
people used to clown on me about it
yeah and they looked at me a certain way
like I was a lesser human being but
Sunday you got the WIPO white boy like
banging bongo drums and he got
and it's like oh this guy's edgy and
different but so you'll hold on a second
man so that's why I like people do feel
a certain way because it's like it's
still a representation for my from how I
see how people see it is still a
representation of inequality yeah like
what in the [ __ ] yeah why is it when I
do it I'm trash but when you do it
because of your skin color it looks cool
it's so funny that they're attacking the
white guys with the dreads because
they're like the furthest those wrong
people to do it right they're like this
nice is little guys that wanna be
peaceful and smoke weed and [ __ ] and
they're getting attacked for like
wanting to be Jamaican or some [ __ ] and
it's like man that's the wrong that's
what I always saw to like the the type
of anger that a lot of minorities had
they would take it out on the white kids
people that were that that were in a
shitty place like us and they they grew
up in the same neighborhoods with us and
it's like that's the wrong people to
take it up but they didn't have access
to to the actual like white people that
was probably mean to them when they're
at the mall or whatever you know it's
like that's not even the group yeah you
know they're just they're just they're
just bullying these kids that are in the
shady places like cuz they're going to
our same schools yeah you know they're
not in a good place but all its sucked
man like we had to have an assembly
because like a lot of the kids were
taking out their anger on the white kids
Jesus and and there was this whole
assembly and we had this like guy
speaking and he was like trying to tell
everybody like they're not you know all
this stuff that you have against them
they're these guys aren't the enemy
they're like they're eating the same
foods and are shady cafeteria they're
going through the same shitty education
like why do it yeah like they're in the
same economic situation right well
you're like attacking the wrong person
yeah but then they're stupid and they
don't know what to do so they they're
just kids and stupid and they don't know
where to take their anger out on yeah so
that's that's where that happens and I
was like do that that just sucks cuz
it's like you see all these people on
the bottom we're all here fighting each
other poor whites poor Asians whatever
even middle class it's like everybody's
just fighting each
and it's like we're so busy doing that
that we're not focusing on getting out
of the shitty situations yeah I think
that's the main thing and that cancel
culture thing just to go back to that it
just is happening a lot because social
media specifically it's highlighting all
the negative stuff and never any other
positive so that's the truth like I was
just talking to you today where when I
went to Texas I've had such a weird
perception of Texas yeah because of what
I've seen and heard when I went there
just from my anecdotal experience people
were generally really [ __ ] nice to us
what I've always said dude link they
didn't come up and go hey what's up
little buddy look at you little [ __ ]
rice paddy boy like they didn't talk to
me like that they were [ __ ] super
respectful like I you know and how it
was told to me that me as an Asian
person would go there you know and
people will I don't know pull my pants
down or some [ __ ] I don't know I faced
way more racism from liberal white
people in California than I ever did
from these conservatives in these states
that were supposed to be afraid of like
when I first started traveling and
seeing the world
sure like maybe you know everyone out
there like nah the south is races
because I live here you don't know what
it's like maybe right but like my
experience going out there meeting
people experiencing just face-to-face
conversations it's always been [ __ ]
Pleasant sometimes even more pleasant
than my California experience but at the
end of the day I can't say millions of
people are all [ __ ] up
either way I can't say California people
we have so many people here but like
just personal experience wise I've dealt
with neo-nazis here in California you're
at the beach I've had like altercations
and [ __ ] like that
but I don't go ahead and say like all
[ __ ] California why people are pieces
of shits right like that's it's hard to
write that off but for some [ __ ]
reason and this is this is kind of a
conspiracy but this is what I think
we're all kind of programmed a little
bit to be afraid of southerners and and
and white people from Texas and all that
because
we're somehow we're it's drilled in my
mind that Republicans equals racists
yeah well it's not true I agree yeah I
don't think it's true because I've met
so many in real life and and I I mean
sure you're gonna have your small number
of extremists right but generally these
people are just normal human beings like
us that just want to work and provide
for their family and [ __ ] have
parties like sure they might be a little
bit different in beliefs or whatever but
there's a lot of things I also believe
in because I'm more in the middle like
I'm moderate right in my political
beliefs but then like before I went
there I had this idea that oh man get
ready Republicans there's gonna be some
white guy that just you know [ __ ]
comes up to me where do we have this
paranoia from you know like it's gotta
be here's my thing liberal education mmm
cuz we're not given an opportunity to
think mmm ever since in in California
the way that we raised the way that
we're kind of taught in the school
system and all that stuff it's a lot of
resentment toward white culture yeah so
instead of like celebrating the
Americanists we go throughout life
learning about how [ __ ] we got by
white people
mmm which is I don't want to bury
history at all it's good to learn from
it but I think what it does to a young
impressionable mind is you grow up
thinking that it's us versus them yeah
and if you're a minority you have to be
Democrat you have to be liberal you have
to because if you don't then you're
gonna be backstabbing your people and
you're gonna be a Uncle Tom by joining
Republicans yeah which to me is so
[ __ ] weird because at the end of the
day we're all American mm-hmm and being
American is about having freedom to
think and choose your own decisions and
be able to debate but still be American
and it goes back to that topic of
but I'm pretty sure we've mentioned
before I'm Jake a muse of identity
politics right right so it's like
because you hear Republican Democrat you
are clearly this right because you're a
Republican you're clearly a trump
supporting racist exactly because you're
a Democrat you're a sensitive little
crybaby [ __ ] yeah there's just no
there's no like room for like okay well
Who am I as an individual yeah it's like
I'm for gay rights but at the same time
I do believe in gun ownership
yeah and gun you know gun rights yeah
it's like you can do both yeah
you can't think for yourself you know
like there's some policies that I agree
on the right like I mean well but the
thing with growing up in LA
highly liberal world like there is no
two-party system in California yeah it's
all liberal like it's all it's either
your extra liberal you're the
progressive left or you're less liberal
or your lesson yeah exactly
and if you if it's it's like if you have
one little [ __ ] Republican ideal then
all of a sudden oh you're you're the
devil it's like what that's so [ __ ]
crazy and people don't people just
sometimes just don't want to have
conversation right
yeah and that's true and and people want
to be highly opinionated about so
essentially something as sensitive and
important as politics yeah they want to
have a strong opinion about stuff that
they haven't even done the research
exactly that's exactly right and it's
scary to me yeah it's scary like I have
relatives like that they go god these
[ __ ] liberal snowflakes it's like
wait hold on a second bro where are you
getting your information on and you know
I've had a conversation yeah at the
relative where you know on Facebook like
she tends to put up a lot of just
liberal bashing [ __ ] she is she is she
right-wing she's hyper right Yeah right
and so just bashing all the stuff and
then you know I had a conversation with
her where basically I asked her I was
like hey so where are you getting this
information from and she goes well it's
all the stuff on Facebook I was like
okay cool but you know you're in a red
state right yeah like you live in a red
state so how these marketing ads work is
this geared towards your bias and she
didn't understand and she thought it was
just [ __ ] no and I was like do you
she goes well that's because you're a
Democrat I was like I'm actually a
registered Republican yeah you know yeah
first of all I was a registered
Republicans because I like the animal I
did when I was 18 so I didn't know what
the [ __ ] I was doing right so it doesn't
really matter so I was like you thought
I was a Democrat just because I lived in
California Yeah right and I told her
like at the end of the day - I don't
give a [ __ ] about my political party you
know that's kind of like canceled
culture go back to it just dismissing
people instead of listening and having a
conversation hyper dismissive and I told
her I was like you're not even willing
to have a conversation with me about a
topic that you're so fired up about yeah
and I asked her I was like okay since
you are so Pro whatever that you are
right if I asked you when you were
voting for these people when it was
Trump or Hillary right aside from you
saying Hillary she's a [ __ ] criminal
and a crook and all this other stuff
aside were saying like Trump is you know
out there for you know the small
personal business type of [ __ ] yeah have
you actually looked at the specific
policies that they're supporting and the
changes that they're going to make
specifically have you even read any of
it yeah she goes yeah I have okay name
name like three or four for me because
there's a lot to me asking you to name
three or four shouldn't be much nothing
yeah they just went back to the stuff
that they're referencing articles
they're reading memes exactly yeah
that's what I get scared about I was
like you are so Pro whatever you're
thinking that you will write all this
jargon and negative garbage on space to
influence people in your circle but you
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about yeah I mean it's the same
thing with religion right like how many
people actually read the Bible that's
what I'm saying you don't [ __ ] even
read the Bible they just [ __ ] assume
what's in the Bible yeah and I'm not
saying that whatever she was saying was
wrong or per se or not but I kind of put
it to her like this - whatever you're
putting up that's Pro whatever you're
thinking I can find something else that
they'll say statistically disproves what
you're saying yeah so who's right or
wrong at this yeah exactly
no you're exactly right dude and what I
don't like about it is if I if I speak
about this like let's say we go to
university and and then and in because
this is my wake-up is like well if I'm a
minority why do I have to be liberal why
do I have to be democratic why is that
my like born into doctrine like why do I
have to be a part of that why why can't
tight there's the green part
there's a libertarian party there's a
Tea Party there's all kinds of different
parties well in different fractions
within the Republican Party you got the
neocons you got like and that's the Bush
administration and those guys you got
the new new-school Republicans that are
kind of like the what's that black girl
she was with Kanye Candace oh yeah you
got the you know Ben Shapiro's and stuff
like that and in within Democrats too
there's different groups of Democrats
right like you got your you know Clinton
crew and then you have this new
generation of progressive left and in
stuff like that and then you have your
Bernie but that's just a straight-up
socialist yeah
and then so like there's just so many
camps everywhere and everyone has the
the the freedom to choose but you know
it's almost as if people don't even want
to listen and try and read and go like
oh I could maybe see myself as a
Republican or maybe I could see myself
as this they don't even they're already
born into it yeah it's in you know
mentioned it before it's that specific
word is people want to be dismissive of
what other people say yeah that's their
first like immediate reaction you don't
know what you're talking about you're
dumb
yeah it's like yo just have a
conversation man be a person exactly
like talk to these people if you are so
highly educated about the subject don't
you think that since you're so vocal on
these social media platforms that you
should probably do your due diligence
and have a conversation with them face
to face when they want it without being
dismissive of what they're about the
same it's funny because a lot of them
can they're just mad mmm you know yeah
you know and I I know where it comes
from because you know us being paranoid
of the south and being afraid of white
people and being afraid of racism and
already assuming that white people will
be racist that is what these guys are
all going through yeah and that
heightened sensitivity is like if if an
ounce of something looks like or
resembles racism they go you [ __ ]
racist I knew it I [ __ ] knew it I was
waiting for this moment you [ __ ]
the
they're waiting to be proved right yeah
you know yeah like I've experienced like
a few races stuff here and there yeah
but it doesn't make me hate the whole
culture just because of a couple of
individuals so if you look at it
statistically from all that like the
corner quote let's say like white people
that you met right I'm pretty sure you
know maybe I'm speaking for people in
California that the one or two times I
was called a [ __ ] the [ __ ] thirty
million other times I wasn't called the
[ __ ] so right am I gonna take those two
negative instances and judge a whole
group of people just on two [ __ ] yeah I
don't think I can do that even when I
was in Louisiana if you couldn't even go
watch it on my channel where I mentioned
this guy when we were it was me and Edie
we were in Louisiana shooting this
Brando for a hotel that we were out
there for and we were walking around
this this white through the trunk
screams at his [ __ ] he goes [ __ ]
chinks or whatever and I got really mad
grab the water bottle it chucked it at
them hmm right and in that moment like
when he said it I couldn't even process
because you think it never happened I
was like what he said yeah anyways he
calls the [ __ ] [ __ ] but what I also
saw was somebody else on a street white
person comes up to us and he goes he
goes I don't don't pay any attention to
that guy that guy's [ __ ] crazy yeah
so what about that what about that guy
Yeah right he kind of like he was the
plus and they were the negative and he
just they just cancelled it yeah it's
like it's like they balanced it out
mm-hmm yeah you know and I don't think
it's my position as an individual to say
that every white person on earth has to
prove to me that they're not racist what
kind of [ __ ] is that who the [ __ ] am
i yeah yeah yeah and yeah I don't know
there's just a whole it just goes deeper
and deeper into this right I just feel
like we're becoming more and more
negative to want to silence people and
be dismissive and separated yeah and I
hate that [ __ ] and then you know it
takes a strong individual to sit in
front of a person that doesn't like you
and listen to them yeah so like if if
there are you know straight-up neo-nazi
all right KKK dudes like I'll sit down
and talk to him because what I mean why
like why'd what is there to be afraid of
it's just words and thoughts and they
don't
there's a reason for a lot of people's
pain and hate yeah there's there's a
root problem a lot of people mask it in
other [ __ ] you know but I what I think
is a lot of people don't have the tools
in their brain to work out these
problems yeah so they blame other things
and sometimes they have legitimate
things but their needs are not getting
met so for example like a biggest
argument from these guys is like they're
taking our jobs
herbs but taking our social security
that's I mean and if you if you really
listen to what they're saying it's like
hey man you know we're doing everything
legal like we're setting up these
construction companies legally we're
doing all these like farm jobs legally
we're paying taxes but here comes an
immigrant that's gonna beat our price
and then we don't get jobs anymore yeah
and this is the voice of poor whites
right and they're not educated they
don't know how to deal with this
situation so all they do is instead of
blaming the farm and then the the lack
of government control on on dude they're
doing due diligence on the construction
companies and all these things right
there it's like this there's just like
loss of you know trust in the government
to make sure that things are being dealt
right and then like they're looking at
these guys which it's it's it kind of
sucks because these illegal guys they
need to do this it's either this or
there they go starving yeah and their
families just like broke and sick and
hungry so it's just a shady situation
that everyone has right and and people
are hiring these poor farm workers I
mean these these illegal immigrants
because the farm workers I mean the farm
owners are getting [ __ ] yeah with
these low prices or whatever you know
they got to do their [ __ ] so all along
the line everybody's kind of [ __ ] and
all we see is the KKK guy doing what
they think is the solution getting
together in [ __ ] burning a cross and
going let's kick out the got there my
leg or my gran
a wall and [ __ ] we need to [ __ ] build
a wall leaving that's the answer but
obviously it's not it goes deeper than
that but they don't have the brain
capacity to understand how to deal with
the problem and on top of that too it's
just easier to be angry at something
then try to find reasons to be happy
about it right so we I had a
conversation with my cousin once again
about it's way easier than to have a
solution the illusions are hard not sure
you got to look for that [ __ ] it's
easier to say like this [ __ ] group is
the reason for my pain yeah that goes
both ways for us to like blame and white
people and going like it's this you see
that this [ __ ] privilege group that
has [ __ ] everything [ __ ] them yeah
that's the reason for my pain okay cuz
my cousin said when when the huge topic
of like illegal immigrants were popping
up right yeah and his argument was well
you know our parents they came here
legally I was like bro that was [ __ ]
like 40 years ago and it was much easier
it was much easier you can't be
dismissive of that fact it's it's a
completely different time you know 9/11
happened yeah but you were you just
forgetting that [ __ ] and what people
don't know is there's limited caps per
country yeah some countries that are in
the friendly list they could come in
easier some people that are like we're
maxed out with Mexicans and Latin
countries so like the only way they know
how and they don't even have the
paperwork in their own country yeah so
it's [ __ ] a [ __ ] man yeah
people just don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about and it drives me
crazy because you know Rain Man the the
guy the savant know who's that so so
Rain Man it they did Dustin Hoffman and
whoever they did they did a movie on
this guy so you know what an autistic
savant is yeah yeah yeah highly
intelligent highly highly intelligent
very skilled in like a specific thing
right they had like for example there
was that kid who they took him in a
helicopter above the city and they told
him to draw what he saw up there yeah
and then he could yes amazing so this
guy they basted a movie on him like he
could read a book like he reads like
three books in a day and like he could
read a page as three seconds or whatever
he remembers everything right but he's
always working through these different
problems in his head and in he he gets
through these Tantrums when he can't
solve a problem right
so he's like he's doing his thing and
he's like why why and his dad's like
it's okay it's okay he goes if they're
illegal why don't they just make them
legal so he was obviously talking about
illegal immigration yeah so this you
know autistic savant even he's bothered
by that because he's like why don't they
just make these people legal but it's
not that easy solution yeah it's easy
but it's in his head it's an easy
solution but like I don't know I think
there's a lot more to it than that and
these topics that's why it's like
abortion it's like it's like these never
[ __ ] ending topics man yeah because
there's an it's not one problem one
solution it's like a [ __ ] of 50
problems oh this is that's what I'm
saying
ignorance is bliss man sometimes I don't
know [ __ ] dude and sometimes it's okay
people to say you don't know [ __ ]
especially when it comes to something
deep like politics I should just
sometimes say I don't know you don't
have a pin you all don't have to have a
hardcore opinion about everything you
know I mean are you a [ __ ]
politicians that that's gonna actually
make a difference yeah what are you
gonna [ __ ] do yeah
sit in the [ __ ] back room drinking
beers and yelling about [ __ ] for the
LAT like four hours straight like what
the [ __ ] yeah
like [ __ ] it's okay to have an opinion
on a lot of things I think and then you
know talk about it is yeah I mean that's
essentially what we do here and what we
do on JK news
you know people and sometimes people
just get mad at opinions too they go
yeah I don't know [ __ ]
yeah no no [ __ ] [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] that's
why it's called an opinion by saying
it's [ __ ] fact you loser I'm sorry
that you got your feelings hurt because
of my opinion then go ahead and cite
your opinion let's talk about what's
crazy what's happening right now and
this is happening in a university space
hmm where people can't have opinions if
it hurts other people oh my god get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] dude
they're not even saying like these
[ __ ] this that or whatever
profanities or anything they're just
like voicing different thoughts yeah and
and and if it doesn't fit the narrative
of I don't know like of the school or
whatever it is like the shut that [ __ ]
down shut it [ __ ] down do the
silencer
you suck that blows my mind because a
university is supposed to be a
playground of thoughts yeah you're
supposed to cultivate that [ __ ] exactly
what the [ __ ] does the debate team
debate about yeah [ __ ] which is
better the carrot cake or rum cake like
yeah [ __ ] man like if you don't have
things that push you right well like
what I don't know like I thought that's
what a university was for yeah people
and I don't want to keep saying and beat
this old drummer saying everybody's so
stuck and sensitive but it's it's
becoming a little apparent that it is
obviously there's like certain stuff
that should be changed yeah and you know
the way people say things and the way
people think yeah however in an open
space I mean we see the [ __ ] in comedy
all the time yeah right what comedy is
supposed to go there and make fun of
ridiculous [ __ ] yeah but they hear
something that's offensive and instead
of just saying this is not for me and
then moving on yeah
they it's the whole I gotta shut this
[ __ ] person around especially in a
comedic space and also in a place of
like a college we're supposed to be
about thought and discussion yeah yeah
yeah they don't even discuss it
yeah yeah what's the whole [ __ ] point
of that and the people just get so quick
to being angry again
that's why I have no idea man it's I
haven't spoken a university in the last
three years it's been a minute oh yeah
but a lot of people tell me that it's
different it's hard it's it's it's hard
because you are going to speak at a
university to only talk about the stuff
that they want to hear and that's a
problem especially though it's a circle
jerk it's a circle jerk right so I'll go
on some of these shows and I've been on
colleges where you know mind you I
learned that I had to be very careful
about what I say and I started hating it
yeah I was like well why am I here are
you here to hear my perspective or am I
here to tell you that you're doing an
awesome job at whatever that you're
doing right now because if you're gonna
ask my opinion about certain things it
may or may not be popular and if you
want to discuss it let's just discuss a
civilly like like for example people had
a bit of a trouble of understanding
where I was saying I don't like it in
Asian Hollywood or some of the most
untalented [ __ ] get to talk about
struggling
you're so right though yeah it's like
it's like [ __ ] true we should support
you know these people no at all I don't
want to support these untalented [ __ ]
cuz they're making us look bad I think
that that's where the identity politics
come yeah where I don't believe just
just because they're Asian I should back
them up yeah like there's politicians
that people were like yeah man he might
be the next president
I don't know [ __ ] this guy yeah
I don't know if he's corrupt there are
there's corrupt Asian politicians that
[ __ ] got caught for running guns and
[ __ ] like why should I like the mayor of
San Francisco no he was a senator a
senator right but he was running guns
with a shrimp boy yeah yeah but I'm like
why why just because just because
they're [ __ ] Asian dude like I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna choose the
person who I believe is gonna represent
my policies the best
yeah they look at you as if you're a
[ __ ] traitor yeah you know and I and
I basically had theirs like well don't
you feel like the reason why some of
these people don't get it is because
that they're Asian I was like hey no it
has everything to do with money and
nothing to do with race yeah oh it's
like there's there's a bigger route to
this problem right and on top of that
route like I I get it to a certain
extent right so some people don't see
these Asian characters in like these
masculine or hyper-feminine like type of
roles and they don't see it then making
a profit off of it
right whatever I understand that my
thing is like if you weren't going to
talk that big I want to see what your
walk is like that's exactly my point -
yeah I want to see it I want to see I
want to see you saying like okay well I
graduated from Juilliard I've taken
these acting classes I'm networking out
there and I'm not getting these
opportunities at all but the people who
are the in anyways the people that I've
met that are so fun I agree with you
because we don't know we don't know all
the Asian actors yeah but we know the
type of Asian actors we're talking about
yeah it's the least talented guys who
are the most vocal yeah I'm angry
because they're not getting the roles
all the people that are getting the
roles that are like getting things they
get it yeah they they don't have a
bitter attitude toward anything yeah and
that's just like any other career
because I've seen there also
yeah that's the point if I saw a
talented dude getting mad about it mmm
then I might agree yeah but like I've
seen their wheels I seen their you know
what it is - it's not just talent it's
work ethic oh yeah you're sure the
laziest [ __ ] that don't even do
auditions and things like that and I
call them out on it and I'm like you
have no right to talk yeah you don't
even take classes you don't even do
anything and people want me to empathize
too with this you know the concept of
Asian people not being considered
attractive I'll say I didn't grow up
with that [ __ ] dude
I a bunch of Asian homies just bang the
[ __ ] out of everything yeah that's
that's that's the crazy thing man yeah
maybe not me yeah I was kind of hideous
but like my other attractive Asian
friends they did quite well see in a
[ __ ] game I didn't grow up feeling ugly
like like as a Asian I loved it man yeah
like I grew up with blacks and Latinas
and in like black hos always wanted to
touch my hair yeah man never been with
the Asian guy like I never occur to me
that I wasn't good enough yeah so I I
want to empathize with a lot of these
Asian kids that grew up in all white
neighborhoods or whatever right like I
get it if you don't look like the people
around you you feel you feel ugly don't
feel like there are white kids that grew
up in all Asian neighborhoods that wish
they were Asian yeah so I get it man but
it's like it's not specific to just
Asians I want people to understand that
I call computer programmers dude yeah
they're always got that people complain
about it that is such a [ __ ] bitch-ass
beta thing to do yeah that it's like bro
you're further if that is a stereotype
right if asian guys are docile they're
not romantic they're not like leading
men you're you're you're acting that
stereotype by not leading yeah you by
you complaining and being depressed
about all of this stuff you know you're
you're falling into that trap right like
you're not living by example and
changing that you know perception at all
and we're talking about this too cuz
like
some of these guys that are saying these
things they're like they don't see me as
like attractive well listen here you
greasy haired [ __ ] like of course nobody
was not about your ethnicity oh yeah
it's your [ __ ] white Skechers and
you're [ __ ] weird jeans and your
greasy ass [ __ ] hair and the fact
that you don't shower don't play don't
put that on our Asian people that that
reminds me of all the ugly guys and
they're not like top dogs but then they
they have so much [ __ ] to say about
women yeah like oh she's not her [ __ ]
titties are small it's like bro have you
looked at you you have no right to judge
man you look like a piece of [ __ ] and in
your [ __ ] judging these actors and
models as if like they're not good
enough it's like what the [ __ ] you can't
even [ __ ] be in the same room with
that but you're not even in the same
realm do ya [ __ ] dare you dude it's
like what blows my mind though is that
going back to what you said is like
every time I go to these shows right mmm
we'll have dinner with some of the
students sometimes they're Asian frat
boys or whatever right and then like I
every year there is a handful of kids
with low self-esteem
that's blaming the whole Asian thing for
their lack of gaiting women and all this
stuff
and I was like what I it started to make
me [ __ ] hate them like I would get
mad yeah like I I started to get so mad
because they wouldn't take
responsibility of their own actions
yeah like like and on top of that how
entitled they were to like the womb like
two women and how they put white women
on a pedestal yeah and then there was
just like oh we only get Asian girls and
it's like what what the [ __ ] does that
mean what's wrong with our women [ __ ]
exactly like they're not good enough
yeah and then that that just made me
like I'm like how do you even start to
think so low like what happened to you
yeah like that made me really mad and
sad at the same time like there's so
many of these low self-esteem
we Cajun guys and also it's not I don't
I highly doubt that its media that did
that to them yeah it's kind of it's
gotta be a weak male father figure it's
gotta be like no real like
you know support system with friends and
it's like highly counterintuitive to
what they're saying that they want right
they're like okay well they don't find
like Asian women attractive like bla bla
bla bla and they're talking about like
this huge disrespect towards Asian
culture I was like bro you're being
disrespected you're you existing right
here which are [ __ ] up hair and you
smell like [ __ ]
like your men disrespect you you have
bad hygiene but you're out here saying
girls don't like Asian guys it's like
nah bro it's just you yeah it's just you
and then you're like you're [ __ ] on
[ __ ] Asian women like what's wrong
with just Asian women liking you what
the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
Asian women are the [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ]
that's why it just blows my mind that
these guys exist you exist they really
do and they think that they're there I
don't know like this is the reality that
they just don't want them to represent
us man exactly and they the thing about
this whole internet [ __ ] is you get a
group of these [ __ ] [ __ ] together
you get them all together and then they
[ __ ] reinforce each other yeah and
it's like this big group of just
bottom-feeder men like yeah just walking
around and beta [ __ ] beta ass like
they're not even beta they're like
[ __ ] beneath Omega or whatever it's
the same concept of oh man I'm just
always in the friend zone
no they just don't like you how about
that how about the girl that you're
after just doesn't find you attractive
it's not because they think of you as a
brother
brothers incest stories man don't worry
about that homie right like and you just
don't know you're not emotionally
intelligent I think that's one of the
biggest problems yeah is that like nerds
are very heady yeah and you know
sometimes you just got to understand how
to communicate and how to just [ __ ]
woo a girl or like talk to them and and
and socialized yeah and sometimes to I
think what I hate that a lot of guys do
just because they've seen so much
Instagram posts and social media [ __ ]
about what defines beauty in a women and
a woman they think that oh that's the
type of woman that I deserve right yeah
the [ __ ] does that mean then what's the
type of man that they deserve then it's
clearly not you face that oh that's
[ __ ] funny man like they want this
hot-ass bikini model that's like [ __ ]
traveling the world with big ass nice
titties and [ __ ] and then like they
can't even make up for it like they
can't they just want to be accepted for
who they are right but they don't have a
job
yep they don't they're not smart like
they're not intelligent they don't have
anything to talk about
yeah like their diet consists of hot
cheetos and ramen yeah they don't work
out and then they sit here and they want
this top-notch grade-a booty but it's
like bro like come on yeah it's like
then you would see this too like I'm
pretty sure you guys had like a group of
dudes you know I'm not just [ __ ] on
men you know this is just the type of
guy I've seen or there's that dude in
the group that every time a girl walks
by he goes man you don't know what I'd
do with that ass but what would you do
with it dude what would you I'll be so
real dude there's some women that I fall
on Instagram I look at their ass and
then I go I wouldn't know what to do
with it I really wouldn't I would not
know what to do with that fat ass I
would just sit there and just be
mesmerized and I'd be scared to do
anything cuz I think she would destroy
my dick that's it that's me being
[ __ ] real and they always look at
these girls then they go I [ __ ] tear
that [ __ ] you would if dude she's like
and stick it in and coming to say yeah
cuz that's exactly what I would do to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up you wouldn't do [ __ ] with
that I feel like a sex guy it's funny
man because I've hung out with guys that
are like good-looking yeah like like
it's a different world for them I know
girls come to them they do the choosing
yeah what's that like I don't know man I
mean giggle my way into that [ __ ] yeah
dude and in and they live in a totally
different world yeah like us normal guys
we got to figure out other ways to
attract ladies yeah personality yeah you
know status like [ __ ] dressing well
whatever it is having charm like but
that initial attraction if you're
good-looking it's easy but it's not
long-lasting right
like a lot of these guys like if they
don't know how to cultivate
relationships they're not gonna have a
fulfilling love life yeah but at least
like when you're young and you just want
ever less women to flock to you yeah
they live in a totally different world
and one of the guys I hang out with he
was used to work at the restaurant with
me shitty car like [ __ ] he was a
busboy like me but he this boy looked
like a Cambodian model homeboy looked
like every girl would [ __ ] like melt
like rescue me like oh I need my dishes
cleaned you know yeah and in the way
women would act around him I was like
wow there's no work people are throwing
themselves at him but he's such a dunce
like he had no [ __ ] clue that they
were hitting on him he was just he
thinks the world is so friendly yeah
it's what's different man that's what
it's like to be a hot person I don't
know what that's like man yeah that
shit's such a fascinating thing to me
like when I observe that [ __ ] I'm like
dude what the [ __ ] because we have
good-looking friends yeah and they just
I see people melt in front of them ah
what the [ __ ] is that like dude yeah no
[ __ ] I know there's a chocolate in my
pants dude that's it
[ __ ] man I just [ __ ] melt people with
laughter that's all I told you man we
get a lot of weights into the [ __ ] dude
and what I mean and to kind of like give
some guys some some guidance like I know
it's [ __ ] hard like I've been there
like it's job it's hard I mean even in a
relationship it's hard like it's
difficult to communicate and and he's
just we're wired different guys and
girls we think different we solve things
different we communicate differently
yeah you know but that's what makes it
awesome and beautiful but the problem is
a lot of these guys don't even try yeah
and they make up [ __ ] and they sit home
all day long but what I want to let you
all know is women are very forgiving hmm
they're not so fixated on simple [ __ ]
like us like what good women yeah yeah
good one good women there's good women
that's worth keeping like they're so
forgiving like you you really don't have
to be the hottest guy on the block
really don't have to be the richest dude
on earth you know in its it's the things
that they want it's pretty humble yeah I
mean you get what you ask for - there's
there's always like a check and balance
system - so you know we even know some
people I wish I could say names but I'm
not like that but you know I have a
friend where she was telling me that she
kind of understood this whole concept of
like she's with somebody right now yeah
and this person on paper is great mm-hmm
right they he provides for her and her
words uh
her her love language is his gifts and
acts of service and it does that to the
max but the problem is they don't really
connect highly on like that he doesn't
really make her laugh they don't really
have that that strong like emotional
connection that she wanted with somebody
and it's like okay and she was with
somebody who did do that but because he
couldn't provide the access service
which is her love language she had to
call it off because that that part
wasn't connecting yeah so you know for
her she you know she's hoping that in
this case that maybe one day they can
connect and you know he's gonna make her
laugh I'm like probably not you know if
that didn't happen in the first couple
months that you got it again oh that is
true it's not that's the honeymoon stage
yeah I mean the other one might work
were the one that made you laugh can do
any other way one day learn to make more
money and give you gifts or whatever hmm
but then not the other way around it's
it's it's so hard you know you're asking
much like people have to understand what
they're asking for and know that it's a
give and take situation people aren't
going to be perfect
yeah and if you expect something out of
somebody you should be able to give them
back something like that in return
mm-hmm that's why I just don't like you
know in for girls - I know like women
who want you know this guy that's so
emotionally attached they know
everything but at the same time you want
the guy to solve all your problems with
throwing gifts at you how what the [ __ ]
does that mean [ __ ] the [ __ ] that you
mean what are you talking about pick
your [ __ ] poison oh yeah you know
it's like the same concept with the dude
that expects to go there'd be this hot
beautiful woman that's just done up 24/7
and they look like [ __ ] hot garbage
yeah oh come on man yeah like be real
with yourself you got
[ __ ] do your part and look really
good - yes your hair all the time like I
mean that's why they say models get with
models man yeah its models get what
model all the touch people yeah exactly
no because it's just it's hot it's
difficult to get with Normie like to get
with normal as folks like it rarely
happens you know yeah get you know what
hot girls out there get yourself an
average do because they will never leave
you
they won't cheat on you they can't get
any better anyways guys that concludes
that episode of genius brain podcast
remember we are up on all audio
platforms if you don't know we talking
about that that iTunes we're talking
about that spotify's e that cast box we
everywhere make sure that if you go
check us out gifts that five-star homie
listen Linda listen Linda cuz we got a
lot of great things and if you're on
that YouTube world make sure you leave
in the comments below about the topics
we should discuss because we here for
you baby listen baby yeah we're geniuses